six months into the war on ukraine
russia's president is calling for a
bigger army vladimir putin has ordered
an increase of 137 000 troops this
morning we have new information on what
it's like to be part of the russian
invasion force deborah pattas spoke with
a russian paratrooper who defected and
is now telling his story we should warn
you some of the images in her report are
disturbing
as missiles rained down on ukraine in
the early hours of 24 february it became
impossible to ignore that vladimir putin
had planned something truly awful
astoundingly many russian soldiers on
the front lines had no idea they had
just invaded ukraine they hadn't even
been told what to do
we just started moving forward
when the shelling began we thought it
was nato approaching us without
ukraine paratrooper pavel fellatif says
he served in russia's 56 air assault
regiment sent to capture her son early
in the conflict
it was only 10 days later when i
realized there is no nato here it's only
ukrainians do you feel tricked
i know that we have been tricked for
many years and everything shown on state
tv has nothing to do with reality
unfortunately
now the same thing is happening
he provided us with documents to support
his claim which we could not
independently verify
he says he was eventually evacuated
because of an injury but until then felt
trapped
the russian paratroop brigade has a
similar attitude to the navy seals of
the us
it is cowardly and shameful to lay down
your weapons and abandon your post
even though we started to realize this
war was wrong we didn't know what to do
with outdated weapons and no food water
or blankets in the freezing cold they
were forced to steal supplies but he
claims many went too far
there was a lot of looting of laptops
and cell phones i understand why but not
only are they paid very little but when
they think they might die tomorrow human
greed takes over
and as for the war crimes russia is
accused of in places like butcher it was
only when he finally had access to the
internet that he read about this he
insists he did not witness any
atrocities
at first i didn't want to believe that
it was true it is horrible for me to
realize that in my army in our country
who did this as the ugly truth began to
sink in
philadelph said many of his comrades
went to extreme lengths to avoid
fighting against ukraine
they would deliberately shoot themselves
in the legs pretend it was an accident
so that they would be sent home and
given a huge compensation why have you
decided to come forward and tell your
story
because if nothing is done there will be
nuclear war where our government will
turn russia into north korea
philadelphia fled russia after
publishing his story but although he
escaped he is not revealing his location
as he is in hiding fearing for his
safety nate
deborah powder in ukraine thank you